sobering news for New Yorkers the
situation is worse than first thought
with the coronavirus rate of infection
doubling every three days we were
looking at a freight train coming across
the country we're now looking at a
bullet train because the numbers are
going up that quickly the governor says
the White House has not prioritized
health to the state that needs it the
most
New York has 25 thousand cases it has 10
times the problem that California has 10
times the problem that Washington State
has you prioritize resources and your
activity and your actions to where they
are needed
New York will need a hundred and forty
thousand hospital beds to care for the
ill they currently have 50,000 available
New York City's largest convention
center has been converted into a
makeshift hospital but it won't be
enough New York is also exploring
converting colleges and hotels to
hospitals as well recently retired
nurses and doctors are being asked to
come back to help fill the need and
globally ventilators are in short supply
New York now needs 30,000 the governor
urged the White House to send him
thousands more that the federal
government has in storage and that are
not being used as for the streets they
remain mostly empty of both people and
cars New York is essentially on lockdown
and given the increased cases of
coronavirus and likely remain like this
for at least many weeks to come Gabriel
Sandow
New York